I have to ask you when you and Meryl
were performing and you were playing the
piano and she was singing were you doing
it live during the movie or did you tape
it did you do it and then playback well
everything you saw was live so yeah what
was the reason I'm sort of hesitant and
answering that is because they we
recorded all of the music at Abbey Road
which was for a guy with this haircut is
a dream all of my dreams came true at
once there you got the part Meryl Streep
and you will be doing this and then
you'll go record an album at abbey road
and I said wait I this is too many
dreams colliding and and then there we
were in Abbey Road you know cutting an
album of opera music so not my comfort
zone or hers and and we we got it we it
took four or five days and we we
desecrated the walls one of the you know
the greatest studios of all time and
then we said and then Stephen said okay
right now you can do it live and we said
well it was sort of a test I think
because Alexandre Desplat who is one of
the many geniuses on this movie told
Stephen hire an actor that can play the
piano and and then do it live because
marijuana to sing all of it and then and
in order to I think to create that kind
of electric alive sort of unknown all of
those those scenes and those reactions
and that you know when especially
because the music is this sort of you
know she's kind of the Titanic and I'm
trying to steer her way to the iceberg
yeah yeah but she's going down but then
there's hope occasionally but then and
I'm just I think if we had had recorded
it and done it to playback while the
editor and
everyone in post-production would have
been a lot younger looking today they
wouldn't have it I just don't think it
would have worked quite the same would
she change it and you know if they say
take two did she do it exactly the same
no never never it didn't matter whether
we were really doing music or not she
she doesn't really do I mean you know I
the you're supposed to to be present and
in the moment and it should always be
different but even great actors and you
tend to sort of find the shape and it's
not that it was wildly wildly to she
what she didn't bang me over the head
with a pot or something in one take just
to liven it up you know was it we were
it was it was all about the scene in the
story and so just naturally things yeah
so so generally things were just would
be different but with the songs it was a
great metaphor especially just as an
actor that it was just inherently going
to be different because sometimes
because there was no rhythm that she had
no rhythm and so then sometimes she had
a little rhythm and sometimes I'd say
that was actually could you make it
worse and then sometimes she'd forget
the words and sometimes I'd lose my spot
and we were sort of locked into this
kind of tandem rock climbing as we
tumbled down the mountain together and
occasionally hooked you know our fingers
in for a second and then and that was
really what that was what was I think
beautiful and working with her obviously
is is a great lesson and surprise but it
was a great thing to look at the music
too because they actually transcribed
the the the actual recording so you
could see what cosme was doing you could
see what Florence was doing you could
see when she skipped a bar dropped two
beats where she lost her way where there
was a you know where he had his four
measures to shine but then he'd slow
down because he knew at the end she
wasn't going to know to come in or he'd
go really fast so she didn't come in
over his big moment and and you could
see actually this and sometimes he
changed keys as though she even knew how
to sing in any sometimes she's saying
all the keys but so it was it was
actually just
of love affair in some way and it was it
was really interesting that's what
accompanists you know do they they help
you know they help their their singer
shine but so you could really see that
that relationship where where it was
this it was totally unknown and and and
how close she really did come to hitting
those notes I'm occasionally honestly
more than not I think that's why it's
strikingly compelling because I think
he'd run away from this movie and from
the music if it was just you know
flailing so she's really close she's
really delicate too and she could hit
the high F above C so that's very hard
to do it is just as Marisa was just the
lower notes where she'd sort of kind of
give because it was all so you could
feel her you know it's like all she
thought about was that high F so the
whole everything before it and
everything after is just kind of oh you
know it's like if I keep that one you
know if you're in a scene and you're
like you know there's this one speech
that's challenging it's like all you're
thinking about is that speech everything
else just falls to [ __ ] because you're
just focusing on one thing and you know
obviously you're not that you shouted
how did you get how did you get this
role with Steven Cruz a big big bang
theory guy or heavy snow I think
something or if someone had recommended
you for an audition it it was it was
sort of um eerily simple actually
Stevens a very very funny odd sweet
laconic eccentric man who doesn't say
many things and it's hard to often tell
what he's how much he's putting you on
so it came about from kathleen chopin
who was the casting director
appropriately named she had sent me an
email i had worked with her on a on a
small film that I had co directed and
written and was in called we'll never
have paris and that came out two years
that was yeah that was a year before and
then i got an email
I thought well this is spam it had Meryl
Streep's names even free I thought this
is you know that's very funny so I I
Alma I didn't understand what's going on
but she said you know Stephen now
Stephens making this movie and and and I
I told him you're the guy and I said
okay so I I read the script and I was
just I was I was blown away and I fought
i started fighting but apparently I
didn't really have to he just he trusted
her immensely and I met with him and we
had a long did you be meeting blending
in in LA he came down and I was so
prepared I had done so much research in
fact I had done so much research that he
asked me to forward him all of my
research because he don't think he had
started yet and then I said but this
character in this and he said can do you
play the piano and I said yes yes but I
think that can you play Mozart and I
said well yeah i play mostly jazz but I
I but can't you play classical and I
just started yes yes I just started
lying and because i wanted to you know
and can you act and play and Ken and I
said yes and and then I we stood up and
he looked me up and down and and I said
sorry this is the best I can do and he
did not laugh again and then as we left
he said what does he look like and I
said who and he said calls me and I said
oh well he looks like me and he said
okay and then he left I was like good
yeah and I got an Airbnb apartment in
Koreatown very fancy to get away from my
my house and live two little children
who I love but they don't let me sit at
the piano ever or do anything that I
want to do except play with them which
is lovely but I was i so i spent about
three months in this place learning a
repertoire of opera and classical i took
a handful of lessons but it was just I
and then and finding the the character
and again I just kept remind myself I'm
an actor I'm an actor no one cares if
you play the piano
um at the end of this they're they're
not going to except for you guys sit
through the credits till the very end to
cos he played the piano but you know I
wanted to I wanted to to do the
character to be an actor in this so I
yeah I was in it but the music was a
major major element and so for those few
months I I just kind of went deep into
this and and did as much research and
immerse myself in this world is there a
lot of information out there on cosmic
know shockingly how did you can the hair
and yeah I mean I there's there's enough
little things and Nick Martin wrote a
brilliant script and that's mainly it's
it's there those are the the clues I
mean but you can there were things to
sort of pluck from from his life but
then there were just things that I that
I was inspired by and one thing I when I
took lessons there the teacher said you
know all the the because I really wanted
to know how how to look like a classical
piano but I thought maybe they'll just
dub me but at least I need to know about
the technique in the posture and the way
they sit and breathe and so I watched a
lot of videos and so but she told me
about this all that the piano players in
the conservatory would have they had
these very long arms she said that they
all would walk around on these very long
arms and because you're told to sort of
imagine this wait at the end of your at
the end of your hands and so when you're
playing it's just you're very relaxed
but it's as though you know you're not
using your elbows or your wrist but it's
as though your hands are being weighed
down to the floor through the keys and I
thought that's such an interesting i
remember when kids would come back from
high school having had like a growth
spurt which i never did but i knew of
people that did have this growth spurt
and they they would always be kind of
like out of their body or like a puppy
and so I just admit it that was a big I
don't know there was something about
that that clued me into this this I just
imagine him somewhat like an alien sort
of coming into his own body and try and
being just discovering learning how to
be human and some
way and being from he was he had been
born in he was born in Mexico and then
he moved to San Antonio when he was very
little and then to New York and I
thought well that again there is this
sort of alien quality in that and and
also his fascination with with muscle
men and what what that might be and what
maybe he might not he might not know
what that was why does he like to look
at these muscle men and body build
especially in the 40s in New York when
you know you're in this there's it's the
sort of it's the place you want to be if
you've got you know any kind of artistic
interest or any any of that but but at
that time you know is very it was
illegal to to be gay and I thought both
maybe he doesn't even know you know you
know those people that that pure moment
of that innocent moment where you
actually just you're in a moment of
discovery I so appreciate you coming
yeah this has been great thank you thank
you for coming thank you guys